we doubled the profit of a five million
dollar business in less than eight weeks
and we followed a single specific
process that i'll break out in this
video and at the very end of the video
i'll walk you through a hypothetical
example of a cavs business that would be
the best business ever that taught
people how to grow their cabs so you can
apply it to your business using the same
process so i want you to imagine that
you have a business or you'd like to
start a business that has a hundred
customers that pay a hundred dollars a
month i'm trying to use the simplest
math possible so 100 customers 100 a
month so that means it's doing 10 000 a
month in revenue now let's assume that
in order to fulfill those customers we
have eight thousand dollars a month in
cost so making two thousand dollars a
month in profit ten thousand dollar top
line two thousand dollars bottom line
eight thousand dollars of cost that's
the business now you rub a magic ipad
a genie appears and this is not any kind
of genie this is a business genie and
this niche genie has one wish that he
can grant you and so he says i can grant
you one wish he says i will double your
business in one of three ways you need
to tell me which way you want me to do
door number one or wish grants of number
one is i will double the amount of
customers that you bring in every month
with this business let's assume that
your churn is not that good so people
stay for on average three months number
two i will double your price so you'll
have the same number of customers and
i'll double how much they pay you every
single month nothing else will change
door number three he says now what i'll
do is i'll double how long they stay so
instead of staying for three months
they'll stay for six months which of the
wishes do you take the genie up on
really be honest in the comments tell me
what your first guess was going to be a
b or c so with door a he doubles it so
now we have 200 customers a month what
happens well if we have 200 customers
paying us a month we now are making
twenty thousand dollars in top line
revenue and assuming everything's scaled
proportionately we would have four
thousand dollars a month in profit and
sixteen thousand dollars a month in cost
double the number of customers we double
the amount of profit doubled our
business awesome let's go to door three
because people are staying twice as long
but you're getting the same amount of
customers per month eventually you will
get to the same equilibrium point as the
first one the exception is that that
wish accomplished does something more
powerful which is it increases your ltv
now because of that and the additional
months that they pay you most businesses
it's more profitable the last one
someone pays than the first one usually
a cost of acquisition cost of onboarding
there's more costs associated with
getting a new customer than keeping
someone if you can double the lifetime
growth profit per customer then your
cost of acquisition can be bigger than
it could in the first example here i
eventually get to the same top line but
i have more bottom line because i didn't
have to spend as much on marketing so
between a and c you pick c now you're
like alright well what about door b so
let's say we had the same hundred
customers but now instead of paying 100
a month they're paying 200 a month we
still have the same cost of fulfilling
them it's 8 000 and our profit went from
2 000 a month to now we have literally
the extra 100 a month that's pure profit
so we six x the profit of the business
with one change for those in the
audience who are thinking but not as
many people would buy so i told you that
we increased how much profit the
business made i'll tell you the one
change that we did was we've looked at
the entire marketplace that were selling
a similar service to theirs and it was
based on our research we felt that the
market could support a 50 higher price
and so we literally and this is already
a pretty expensive thing we literally
did nothing but add 50 to the price and
changed nothing about the product and
guess what happened more people bought
why because when something becomes more
expensive people perceive its value in a
higher way and because of the brand that
the person had it was more aligned with
the person to have a higher price tag
now most times in most markets you have
supply and demand and when the price
goes up demand goes down in most markets
now not all markets and more times than
not it doesn't drop by the same
proportion so if you double the price
sometimes you sell a third fewer but if
you double the price and you've 6x the
profit potential on a customer if i 6x
my profit on a potential customer and i
do it at uh two-thirds the price then i
tripled the profit of the business still
you still make way more money and so
finding the absolute perfect point of
profit many times comes from raising the
price and pricing is one of those very
interesting things because it's very
tied to emotions a lot of people are
very afraid of raising the price because
they don't want to break it i want to
talk to you about how to raise the price
if that is your goal which is why the
number one lever that you have on
profits is pricing and constantly
testing a lot of people's tests split
test their pages they split test their
scripts they split test their offers but
the thing that they forget to test is
their price and it's the strongest lever
of all three levers okay so let's walk
through a hypothetical business and the
steps that we would need to take in
order to increase the price if that's
what we decided was the right call so
the first thing we would do is we'd
survey the existing audience using the
van west store pricing survey and let's
say this business sold a 12-week grow
your cabs program and let's say it was
1200 for 12 weeks very simple and on the
first third of the survey we're trying
to find out more about the customer so
we're like hey you know what was the
main reason that you bought this was
there an event that was coming up that
incentivized you to do it what's your
income level what's your job what was
the primary way that you found out about
us right so it's like okay these are the
things that we know about the avatar and
so we've got those client demographics
okay second part is the four questions
of the van west what if it was super
expensive what if we're way too cheap
what if it were a stretch and then what
if it were a bargain right those are the
four questions now we say of all the
things that we do in our cavs program
which is the book the training the
nutrition the stretching thing that we
have the one-on-one calls for
accountability the body system that
we've put together so you have an
accountability buddy like all of these
things that we do in our value stack
which of these if we only had one of
them you would keep and which of these
if we got rid of one you would lose and
not care you take that data number one
number two now we communicate it
internally first all right so we got to
communicate to the team we got a
community of sales team security
marketing team then we communicate it to
our customers this is what's happening
this is why it's happening past present
future this is what we did to get here
this is why it's important now this is
what we're trying to do later we're
investing the business because we want
to fulfill our promises finally now we
bring it up to the new customers who are
coming in so we hit our lists up to let
them know we had the urgency in step
four and then the last step is now we
officially have this new price now what
we want to do now is expect the fact
that the change in price will probably
result in fewer sales by total volume
and the reason for that is because we
cleared the pipeline before the price
change it happens once you have that you
have to let it shake out you have to let
it settle and it's really trying it's
very difficult to do that because it
takes guts but once you make that you
let it settle then you just do the math
and let the math do the talking but if
you sell it at twice the price you make
more money so in our hypothetical cab
scenario let's say we bumped it to 2000
or 3000 because we found out that that
was the price that was right at that
sweet spot that was the stretch but
they'd still do it we might have just
two or three x the profit of the
business by making that one change and
maybe because cavs are the coolest thing
ever got even more people to buy it
because they thought they really could
get the results that we said we were
gonna help them experience if this was
interesting to you go to acquisition.com
third video is on pricing you can watch
more about pricing as it applies to your
business it's absolutely free you don't
need opt-in or anything you can just
watch it